Ich bin der Verstärkungsvorsitzende und möchte Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Aber bevor ich damit beginne bitte ich um Ihre persönliche Information. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Herr Doktor, ich bin sehr schlecht und ich fühle mich nicht gut. Aber ich habe meine alle persönlichen Daten gegeben. Warum habe ich Sie wieder gefragt?
Ja, ich verstehe. Aber um eine Verwechslung zu vermeiden, brauche ich wieder Ihre persönliche Information.
Achso. Mein Name ist Theo Zarbowski.
Theo Zarbowski. Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname langsam bestabeln?
Tavi Theodor, Javi Heinrich, Evi Emil, Ovi Otto. Und mein Nachname ist Samuel, Avi Anton, Evi Richard, BW Bertha, Ovi Otto, Victor V.
Kavi Victor, es wie wieder Samuel, Kavi Kaufmann, Evi Idam.
Zarbowski. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Zarbowski?
Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Wann würden Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin an den 30.12.1967 entgegen.
Oder 1987?
Ich bin an den 31.12.1967.
Sie sind 69 Jahre alt, richtig?
Ist das falsch? 67, Herr Doktor.
Aber Sie sind 69 Jahre alt, richtig?
59. Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Alles klar. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,83 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ungefähr 74,3 Kilo.
74,3 Kilo. Und Herr Zarbowski, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie müde sind. Seit wann sind Sie müde?
Ich bin total kaputt und mir ist schlecht.
Seit vier Wochen habe ich sehr starke Bauchschmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Könnten Sie mir zeigen, wo genau Sie befinden?
Ganz im Oberbauch.
Ich konnte nicht ganz genau beschreiben, dass es sehr schlimm ist.
Befinden Sie sich eher auf der rechten Seite, links oder mittels?
Kann man so sagen, ja, mittler, aber im Oberbauch.
Was meinen Sie mit dem Strahlen?
Ich meine, die Schmerzen bleiben nicht in einer Körperteile, sondern bereiten sich auf andere Körperteile auf.
In den Rücken, ja.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben? Sind Sie eher durchdruckend, brennend, ziehend, kraftartig?
Manchmal kolikartig, aber ziehend und mit starken Oberbauchschmerzen.
Und dann langsam, langsam zu nehmen.
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Treten die Schmerzen attraktiv auf oder sind sie dauerhaft vorhanden?
Mein Bauchschmerzen ist derzeit sehr schlimm, aber im Verlauf der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Aber kolikartig manchmal, kann man sagen, ein bisschen wehlen für mich.
Okay. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10? Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen, 10 am starksten Schmerzen bedeutet?
Ungefähr 6.
Und gab es Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Vor drei Wochen habe ich nach dem Eiersalat mit ein bisschen Brot und Butter gegessen.
Und dann, ja, das war es ein bisschen stärker geworden. Und dann, ja, nach dem Essen kann man so sagen, ja.
Nach dem Eiersalat und?
Mit ein bisschen Brot und Butter.
Butter, okay.
Ein bisschen fettiger.
Ja, ja, das verstehe ich.
Fettiger.
Und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Herr Doktor, ich bin in Ruhestand. Ist das ganz besser. Aber wenn ich mich ein bisschen bewege und oder stehe, ist stärker.
Und wenn ich in Ruhe bleibe, ist es schwächer geworden.
Ja, das verstehe. Und Herr Saburski, haben Sie dagegen Medikamente eingenommen?
Medikamente? Ich habe keine Medikamente, Herr Doktor. Ich bin früher sehr gesund. Ich war sehr gesund. Aber ich habe lange Zeit zum Arzt nicht gegangen.
Sie haben gegen diese Schmerzen keine Medikamente eingenommen, richtig?
Ja, ungefähr. Ich habe meinen Hausarzt diesen Namen vergessen. Ich war sehr gesund früher, aber in der letzten Zeit habe ich sehr starke Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Hatten Sie schon einmal keine ähnliche Beschwerden, richtig?
Ja, aber seit drei Wochen habe ich ähnliche Beschwerden. Aber seit drei Wochen, drei Monate habe ich ähnliche Beschwerden. Aber seit drei Wochen ist das schlimmer geworden.
Ja, das verstehe. Und haben Sie Fieber? Fühlen Sie sich febri?
Fieber? Nein, ich habe keine Fieber.
Alles klar. Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Seit drei Wochen habe ich kaum Appetit. Ich fühle mich nicht so gut. Ich möchte nicht etwas essen. Besonders etwas Fettiges essen.
Fettiges Essen. Zum Beispiel Kartoffeln, Butter und Schokolade. Und habe ich sehr starke Schmerzen. Aber wenn ich ruhe oder ich habe kein Essen gegessen, ist alles in Ordnung.
Alles klar. Und Herr Sabosky, Sie haben erwarnt, dass Sie Übelkeit haben. Und haben Sie erbrochen?
Erbrochen? Nein, ich habe Übelkeit. Aber seit drei Wochen habe ich mit meinen Beschwerden Übelkeit. Und auch ist es schlimmer geworden. Aber ich habe keine. Ich musste nicht erbrechen.
Alles klar. Und haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen?
Schwierigkeiten? Was meinen Sie?
Zum Beispiel Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen und keine brennende Gefühle. Aber mein Urin ist ein bisschen dunkel.
Wie Altbier?
Wie Tee. Kann man so sagen.
Und haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Stuhlgang?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen und keine Beschwerden. Aber mein Stuhl ist ein bisschen glänzend.
Ich habe immer mehrmals zur Toilette gehen müssen. Aber ich habe keine Blut bemerkt. Ein bisschen dünner.
Und Herr Sabosky, leiden Sie an einer chronischen Erkrankung? Eine dauerhafte Erkrankung? Also Bluthochdruck, Blutzucker?
Vor zehn Jahren hat mein Hausarzt schon gesagt, dass ich eine Hühnerauge hatte. Was ist das? Soll ich einen Augenarzt besuchen, Herr Doktor?
Nein, das ist eine orthopädische Erkrankung. Aber mit bequemen Schuhen wird es gut behandelt. Sie sollten einen Orthopäden einen Termin vereinbaren.
Ach so, danke schön.
Das ist keine Augenerkrankung.
Nur, ich habe keine Augen.
Und nehmen Sie Medikamente ein?
Medikamente? Ich habe keine Medikamente.
Alles klar.
Früher war ich sehr gesund.
Alles klar, super.
Herr Sabosky, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Vor 29 Jahren hatte ich ein Unterschenkelknochenbruch. Ich hatte eine Operation damals.
Nach der Operation hatte ich eine sehr schlechte Situation und musste vier Pax Blut bekommen. Das war sehr schlecht.
Das tut mir leid, dass Sie diese Erfahrungen gemacht haben. Was hat damals passiert? Sind Sie im Krankenhaus geblieben?
Ich vermute, dass ich eine Blutung hatte. Aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Okay, das verstehe. Und sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Allergisch? Ich habe keine Allergie.
Und haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Unverträglichkeit? Was meint Sie?
Allergie ist eine systemische Reaktion wie Juckreis, Hauttötung. Aber Unverträglichkeit ist eher eine lokale Reaktion.
Insbesondere im Verdauungssystem, zum Beispiel Laktos, Milchsäure oder Gluten-Unverträglichkeit.
Mein Freund hat schon gesagt, dass ich eine Wasserallergie habe. Was meint Sie?
Das ist unwahrscheinlich. Sie hat einen Scherz gemacht.
Wenn ich ein bisschen Alkohol trinke und ich mehrmals zur Toilette gehen muss, dann sagt mein Freund schon, dass er weniger Alkohol trinke.
Aber mein Freund hat schon gesagt, dass ich eine Wasserallergie habe.
Ja, das habe ich verstanden. Sie haben einen Scherz gemacht. Und Herr Sabosky, rauchen Sie?
Seit 40 Jahren rauche ich 20 Zigaretten täglich, Herr Doktor.
Einpacken, richtig?
Ja, einpacken.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Herr Doktor, ich habe schon gesagt, dass ich immer Alkohol trinke und 3 bis 4 Flaschen Bier täglich trinke.
Ich trinke ca. seit 40 Jahren mindestens 2 Schnaps täglich.
Wenn ich ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen habe und immer Schnaps trinke, dann geht es gut.
Und bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage. Hattet ihr Kontakt zu Drogen?
Ja, vor einem Jahr. Und kann man bis 3 Jungen trinken, alle 2 bis 3 Wochen. Aber in letzter Zeit habe ich nicht.
Alles klar. Ein Drogenkonsum kann zu Gesundheitsproblemen führen. Aber Sie sind...
Herr Doktor, ich habe sehr starke Bauchschmerzen. Können Sie bitte mir helfen? Aber Alkohol ist sehr schön für mich. Ja, das geht.
Herr Strabovski, möchten Sie Medikamente momentan oder können Sie bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ich kann aushalten, ja.
Okay. Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Beide sind verstorben. Mein Vater ist ein Dickdarmkrebs mit 60 Jahren verstorben.
Und meine Mutter ist ein Kulare-Ursache mit 65 Jahren verstorben. Ja, Herr Doktor.
Und mein Großvater hatte einen Magenkrebs.
Magenkrebs oder Dickdarmkrebs?
Mein Großvater hatte Magenkrebs, aber mein Vater hatte Dickdarmkrebs.
Kann ich Krebs sein?
Ich gehe momentan nicht davon aus. Aber um sicher zu gehen, brauche ich weitere Untersuchungen.
Dann können wir Ihnen genau erklären, ob Sie einen Krebs haben. Aber momentan gehe ich nicht davon aus.
Herzlichen Beleid, Frau Strabovski, zum Verlust Ihrer Familie. Das tut mir leid.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Keine Geschwister.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin seit 10 Jahren verheiratet. Ich habe eine Tochter, aber ich hatte keinen Kontakt mit meiner Tochter.
Das tut mir leid.
Ich bin seit fünf Jahren arbeitslos, Herr Doktor. Aber früher war ich Schloss und Dreher. Aber ich bin immer zu Hause.
Herr Strabovski, ich glaube, ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt und alle relevanten Informationen gesammelt.
Nach dem Angaben denke ich am ehesten eine Bauchspeildrußentzündung. Aber das ist nur ein Verdacht und muss durch weitere Untersuchungen bestätigt werden.
Zunächst würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen und ihre Vitalparameter messen.
Dann würde ich ein EKG schreiben lassen, um eine kardiologische Ursache auszuschließen.
Anschließend würde ich einen Bauch-Utraschall durchführen.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Muss ich hierbleiben, Herr Doktor?
Die weitere Untersuchungen sollten Sie hierbleiben. Sie sollten Ihre Gesundheit priorisieren.
Wie viele Stunden dauern Sie?
Das kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Okay, danke schön.
Wir sind hier, um Ihnen zu helfen und die beste medizinische Versorgung zu bieten. Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Danke schön, Herr Doktor.
Ich weiß diesen Patient sehr gut. Er spricht sehr schlecht. Er ist nicht schüchtern.
Ich sage ihm das.
Er spricht sehr schlecht, ist nicht schüchtern.
Als ich ihn höre, habe ich ihn nicht gedacht, dass er an Allergik geblieben ist.
Er ist nicht im Internet. Wir hören Sie.
Keine Frage, wir hören Sie.
Ich habe diese Frage gestellt.
Gibt es jemanden, der Fragen hat?
Vielleicht der Patient hat berichtet, dass er auch Übelkeit hat.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Dünner Stuhl.
Er hat keinen Durchfall, sondern Dünner Stuhl.
Ich habe nicht so gesagt.
Übelkeit, auch Durchfall, Übelkeit, Erbrechen?
Dünner Stuhl.
Neben Stuhlprobleme gibt es auch Übelkeit und Erbrechen?
Ich kann es nicht ohne Erbrechen, aber es ist schlecht für mich.
Vielleicht diese Frage kann auch gestellt werden.
Haben andere nach dem Essen auch ähnliche Beschwerde gehabt?
Weil der Patient unter Übelkeit auch Stuhlprobleme hat?
Können Sie etwas sagen?
Natürlich.
Die Reaktionen der Töpke waren sehr schön.
Und...
...jetzt das Ende.
Ist es in Pankratik, aber es gibt eine Polykartik?
Ich frage nur, ob es nur eine Informationstelle gibt.
In Pankratik?
Mhm.
Also Gürtel, Vermeck und Schmersen.
Gürtel kann es nicht sagen.
Nein, er kann es nicht sagen.
In Rücken, in Rücken, in Straylen, in Iskenhofen und in Malewaizen.
Es gibt eine Polykartik, aber es gibt auch eine, die nicht in Straylen ist.
Aber wir werden es in einer Moment sprechen.
Und es gibt auch eine Polythiase.
Natürlich, die muss man anstecken.
Ja, die muss man anstecken.
Okay, danke.
Ich bin bereit.
Ich möchte Sie fragen, ob ein Lehrer eine Bildung gemacht hat?
Das kann man machen.
Okay.
Das ist eine technische Frage.
Ich bin auch gespannt, ob Sie das machen.
Nein, ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Also kann man das machen?
Ja, ich glaube so.
Ja, wir können es.
Okay.
Möchtest du einen Labor anrufen?
Ja.
Zunächst muss ich die Uhrzeit umstellen.
20 Minuten.
Okay.
Ja, bitte schön.
Ja, oder ...
Okay, ich mache es.
Ja, hier bitte, Demir.
Ich bin von der Amlabo.
Herr Lorenz,
die Thrombose werden
1000 pro Mikro Liter.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich bin von der Amlabo.
Schönen Tag.
Nehmen Sie bitte die Klasse.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Kollege, was machen Sie heute?
Guten Tag.
Demir ist mein Name.
Ich bin der neue Assistent.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin
in der Notaufnahme vorstellen.
Bevor ich damit beginne,
möchte ich Ihnen einen wichtigen Labor anrufen.
Eine Kollegin aus dem Labor hat mir
telefonisch mitgeteilt, dass der Thrombosythenwert
bei 20.000 pro Mikro Liter liegt.
Bei 20.000 pro Mikro Liter liegt.
Dieser Wert ist sehr stark.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
20.000.
Das ist ein Thrombosythenwert.
Das ist ein starkes Initri.
Ja, Thrombosythenwert.
Wie ist das normale Wert?
Normale Wert liegt zwischen
1.025 und 600.000.
1.025.000, 600.000.
600 oder 400.000.
Aber 20.000 ist zu wenig.
Ja, richtig.
Welche Probleme haben Sie?
Die Probleme sind, dass die Klasse
nicht mehr in der Notaufnahme ist.
Ja, richtig.
Welche Probleme könnte der Patient
oder die Patienten haben?
Mit welchen Symptomen kann der Patient
mit dieser Wert kommen?
Diese ausgeprägte Thrombosythenwert
kann zu Blutungen, Nasenblutungen,
PtC, Purpura oder intrakranial
in schlimmsten Fall zu intrakranial Blutungen führen.
Das ist sehr dringend.
Richtig?
Ja, richtig. Deswegen würde ich Ihnen mitteilen.
Vielen Dank für diese Mitteilung.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Welche Ursachen sind möglich?
Ja, mögliche Ursachen sind
Knochenmarktsuppression, Infektion, Medikamente.
Zum Beispiel
Ablastiganämie oder Leukemi.
Welche Medikamente meinen Sie?
Zum Beispiel?
Soweit ich weiß, ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
aber soweit ich weiß...
Ja, ich habe vergessen. Das tut mir leid.
Kein Problem. Alles in Ordnung.
Herr Kollege, wir sprechen zusammen.
Heparin, ist das möglich?
Ja, Heparin, richtig.
Welche
Krankheiten,
welche Vorerkrankungen könnte das sein?
ITP meinen Sie?
Trombostöpini?
Ja, ITP kann zu Trombostöpini sein.
Was meinen Sie ITP?
Idiopathische Trombostische Purpura.
Ja, genau.
Und welche
Gründe könnte es sein für
Idiopathische Trombostöpini Purpura?
Soweit ich mich erinnere,
das ist eine autominologische Erkrankung.
Und es gibt eine Gründe,
dass es idiopathisch ist.
Idiopathische bedeutet, wir können nicht
einen echten Grund finden.
Ja, richtig.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen,
welche Symptome
der Patient oder die Patienten haben?
Sie haben gesagt Blutung, Ptäche...
Nasenblutungen, Ptäche.
Ptäche, kleines Ptäche,
kleine Ptäche oder große Ptäche?
Oder ganz ober, ganz körperlich?
Ptäche oder nur zum Beispiel
an einer Hand?
Oder im Gesicht?
Ich glaube,
ja am meisten...
Ich meine verbreitende, ausbreitende Ptäche
oder in ganzem Körperteil?
Oder nur ein kleines Bereich?
Ich glaube, am meisten im Hand.
Aber das kann
im Gesicht vorhanden sein.
Okay.
Ja, Hämatom, ist das möglich?
Ja, natürlich ist es möglich.
Gastrointestinal Blutung?
Gastrointestinal Blutung oder intrakranial Blutung.
Ja, das bedeutet,
dass man darauf
bei dieser Situation achten sollte.
Bei intrakranial Blutungen
achten sollte man
Zynkop oder...
Okay, wir brauchen eine wichtige
neurologische Untersuchung, ich glaube.
Und was planen Sie,
um diese Situation
zu verhindern?
Oder wenn Sie diese
Patienten haben könnten,
welche Therapie
können Sie planen?
Das ist nicht meine Patientin.
Zunächst brauche ich körperliche Untersuchung.
Zunächst brauche ich Patienten zu sehen.
Ich würde nur Ihnen mitteilen.
Ich verstehe, aber ich möchte
über diese Situation sprechen.
Wenn Sie möchten. Möchten Sie?
Ja, natürlich. Aber zunächst brauche ich die Patienten untersuchen.
Okay, Sie meinen,
wir brauchen mehr Informationen und wir können
durch eine Untersuchung
diese Informationen erhalten.
Okay, und
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Patienten Blutungen haben.
Das ist auch eine Komplikation, richtig?
Ja, richtig. Und die Therapie haben Sie
erwähnt, aber tut mir leid,
zu unterbrechen.
Die Therapie richtet sich nach der Ursache.
Okay, okay.
Sollen wir warten oder...
Zunächst...
Ist das eine dringende Situation?
Ich meine, ist das ein Notfall?
Ja, ich weiß. Das ist ein Notfall.
Wir können
frisch Plasme geben.
Meinen Sie, ja, Bluttransfusion?
Ja, richtig.
Okay. Aber wenn es eine
Auto-Unmin-Probleme hat,
gibt es keine?
Okay.
Okay, vielen Dank. Ja, ich hatte Sie gehört,
dass Sie ja neu angefangen haben,
aber wir konnten nicht kennenlernen.
Und ich möchte ja wissen,
wie Sie sind. Könnten Sie
sich bitte vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich. Ich bin Ibrahim Demir.
Ich komme aus der Türkei. Ich bin 34 Jahre alt.
Und ich bin seit...
Wie alt sind Sie?
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
34 Jahre alt.
Das bedeutet, Sie haben Erfahrungen
in der Türkei?
Ja, ich habe fünf Jahre lang in der Türkei gearbeitet,
im Krankenwagen.
Das ist interessant.
Ja, das ist sehr interessant.
Und ich habe ein paar
Nachrichten gelesen und gesehen.
Ja, in der Türkei
gibt es, ich glaube, ein paar Probleme
beim Krankenwagen.
Nein, habe ich keine Probleme. Hat ich keine Probleme
in der Türkei.
Oder können Sie schlechte
vorhanden oder haben?
Oder greifen Sie?
Können die Menschen
greifen Sie an?
Ich wusste nicht. In meinem Heimatland
habe ich gearbeitet. Und dort habe ich
nur eine
ärztliche Krankenwagen volllegt.
Ja, fünf Jahre.
Ja, okay. Fünf Jahre lang haben Sie Erfahrung
beim Krankenwagen. Und
warum sind Sie hier?
Ja, ich bin hier gekommen,
weil menschliche Werte
in Deutschland eher ausgeprägt
als in der Türkei.
Das ist sehr interessant.
Seit wann sind Sie hier?
Seit ungefähr drei Jahren.
Drei Jahre, oh, sehr lang. Und ich glaube,
Sie haben Deutsch hier gelernt, oder?
Ja, bis jetzt habe ich Deutschkurs besucht
und
Falschprachprüfungkurs besucht. Und
im Dezember habe ich eine Hospitalisierung
im Müllheim an der Ruhr gemacht.
Im Allgemeinen Chirurgie.
Sehr gut.
Dort habe ich an der Operation teilgenommen.
Im Zentralnutzaufnahme habe ich
den Patienten aufgenommen,
zu helfen.
Das ist sehr gut. Und Sie haben auch Erfahrungen
in der Türkei mit
Krankenwagen. Und diese Situationen sind ähnlich, ich glaube.
Ja, danke.
Und was planen Sie
in Deutschland? Möchten Sie zu lange hier bleiben?
Oder was planen Sie?
Ja, natürlich. Ich interessiere mich für
innere Medizin. Wenn ich diese Prüfung bestehe,
möchte ich eine Stelle
in der Medizin finden.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ich hoffe, Sie können bestehen und Sie können finden.
Danke, Herr Oberst.
Und, haben Sie
noch weitere Patienten?
Ja, Herr Oberst, ich habe einen neuen Patienten
in der Notaufnahme aufgenommen.
Es handelt sich um Herr Theo
Saborski, ein 59-jähriger Patienten.
Geboren am
30.12.1967.
Er ist 1,87 Meter groß
und er wiegt aktuell
74,3 Kilogramm.
Er stellt sich
heute bei uns
seit vier Wochen bestehenden
langsam einsetzenden
progradienten Oberbauchschmerzen.
Seit vier Wochen?
Ja, seit vier Wochen.
Bestehenden
langsam einsetzenden
progradienten Oberbauchschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in die
Rücken aus. Sie beschreibt die
Schmerzen als krampfartig
und sie stuft die Schmerzen auf eine
Schmerzkala von 0 bis 10 mit 6 von 10 ein.
Als Auslöser wurde
fettliches Essen genannt.
Gestern hat er
Eiersalat
mit Butter und Brot
gegessen.
Und Verstärkungfaktor
wurde mit Bewegung und Stehen genannt.
Die Linderungfaktor dagegen
wurde mit U.
Die Vegetative Anamnese
sind...
Gibt es noch weitere
15 Lebensmittel,
die seine Schmerzen verstärken?
Soweit ich...
Sie haben gesagt, fettiges Essen.
Ja. Zum Beispiel gibt es
ein weiteres bestimmtes
Lebensmittel, wie Gewürzesessen, wie scharfes Essen.
Ich glaube,
er hat es nicht genannt, aber
ich konnte verpassen.
Oder wenn der
Patient nüchtern ist,
oder Hunger hat,
hat der Patient weniger Schmerzen, weniger Probleme.
Oder nach dem Essen.
Besonders nach dem fettiges Essen
hat der Patient diese Probleme.
Oder nach allem Essen. Nach dem immer Essen.
Nein, fettiges Essen.
Wenn er nicht isst,
hat er keine Becher.
Okay.
Weiter bitte.
Die Vegetative Anamnese sind insomni,
in Appetens,
Nausea, ohne Emesis,
auffällig.
Bei Stuhlgang hat sie...
hat er gesagt,
dass er eine glänzende
Schmerzen hat.
Das ist Fettstuhl.
Und bei
Ürin hat er gesagt,
dass er Polaküsüri hat.
Polaküsüri, okay.
Was noch?
Gibt es noch weitere Veränderungen?
Ja, du hast es schon gesagt.
Ja, ich habe es schon gesagt.
Gibt es noch weitere Veränderungen?
Ja, dunkle Urin.
Und der Patient hatte auch
Ausstrahlung in den Rücken.
Ja, in den Rücken.
Hat der Patient flanken Schmerzen?
Ich glaube, nein.
Okay. Sie können bei der Untersuchung
diese Frage stellen.
Wir können auch den Patienten untersuchen.
Und dunkle Urin. Seit wann
der Patient solche Beschwerden?
Ich meine dunkle Urin
und hell-braune
Stuhlveränderung.
Während der Untersuchung
frage ich seit wann haben Sie...
Okay. Oder
hat der Patient Hautfarbeveränderung?
Ja, auch diese Frage frage ich.
Oder hat der Patient
andere begleitende Symptome
wie U-Kreis?
Okay, Sie können bei der Untersuchung diese Frage stellen.
Okay. Das ist ja alles
in Ordnung?
Das mache ich. Okay. Was noch?
Und als Erkrankung
hatte Sie vor
10 Jahren Klaus
für eine Augen. Was meinen Sie?
Was meinen Sie? Das ist eine orthopädische
Erkrankung.
Aufgrund von Drücken oder Reibung.
Aber mit bequemer Schuhe
wird es gut behandelt.
Okay. Aber seit 10 Jahren?
Vor 10 Jahren.
Okay. Vor 10 Jahren. Okay.
Was noch?
Er nimmt keine Medikamente ein.
Er wurde vor 29 Jahren...
Kein Medikament? Ja.
Seit 4 Wochen hat der Patient
starke Bauchschmerzen,
Oberbauch und
er hat keine Medikamente
eingenommen. Ja, richtig. Oder
war der Patient bei diesem Zeitraum
beim Hausarzt oder andere Arzt?
Er hat seinen Hausarzt nicht besucht.
Okay.
Der Patient,
er ist 59 Jahre alt
und hat eine Bauchschmerzen. Ich habe Angst,
Herr Kollege. Hat der Patient
Atemnot, Dyspina?
Vielleicht könnte es auch
Myokardinfarkt sein?
Ja, könnte es sein. Okay. Haben Sie unterbrochen?
Bauchschmerzen kann unter Bauchschmerzen
verstecken. Ja, richtig.
Okay. Bitte achten Sie darauf
eine weiterkömmliche Untersuchung. Und hat der Patient
weitere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, das war es.
Okay. Gibt es eine Operationgeschichte?
Ja. Er wurde vor 29 Jahren
vor 20 Jahren
eine Unterschenkeloperation durchgeführt.
Nach der Operation
hat er
eine Unverträglichkeit gelitten.
Ah, Sepsis. Okay.
Hat der Patient Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Sie ist nicht allergisch. Sie hat keine Unverträglichkeit.
Sie ist Raucher
40 Packungen.
Er raucht 40 Packungen.
Und er drinkt
40 Jahre. Ja, verstehe.
40 Jahre raucht er
ein Packungszigarette.
Das bedeutet 40 Packungen.
Und er trinkt 3 bis 4
Bier täglich. Circa 40 Jahre.
Das ist zu viel.
Ja, zu viel. Sie haben recht, Herr Kollege.
Sie trinkt mindestens 2 Schnaps.
Das ist auch zu viel. Ja, genau.
Sie haben recht.
Er hatte Kontakt
mit 2 bis 3 Joint.
Aber momentan hat er keinen Kontakt
nach
dieser Aussage.
Aussage oder...
Laut des Patienten, meinen Sie?
Ja, laut des Patienten.
Aber momentan hat er keinen Kontakt.
Keinen Kontakt, okay. Sehr gut.
Und wie sieht seine Familie aus?
Ja, ihr Vater ist an
Darmkarschino.
Was meint er?
Kolonkarschino gestorben.
Ja, genau.
Ihr Opa hat
an Darmkarschino gestorben.
Okay, Opa Magenkarschino.
Seine Mutter ist
verstorben.
Aber die Aussage
ist unklar.
Oder nicht bekannt, okay. Weiter.
Ist der Patient vollständig gehypt?
Leider habe ich
nicht gefragt, weil ich
keine Zeit hatte.
Okay, weiter bitte. Oder
hatte der Patient
Reisegeschichte in letzter Zeit?
Während der körperliche Untersuchung
frage ich. Ja, sehr gut. Aber sie
sind geschieden und hat eine gesunde
Tochter. Ich bin nicht geschieden.
Er ist geschieden.
Aber sie haben gesagt, sie sind geschieden.
Okay, vielleicht habe ich falsch verstanden.
Okay.
Und er hat eine Tochter.
Er hat eine Tochter. Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist gesund.
Sehr gut. Und mit wem
lebt er?
Während der körperliche Untersuchung
frage ich. Okay, sehr gut.
Ich notiere.
Sehr gut, Herr Kollege.
Was haben Sie?
Oder welche Verdachtdiagnose
haben Sie? Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten
auf die Schmerzen.
Weil sie
Oberbauchschmerzen und
Übelkeit und die Schmerzen
strahlen in der Rücken aus. Und am
wichtigste ist dunkler Urin und
glänzender Stuhl.
Das deutet auf Pancreatitis.
Ja. Und
Choledokalitiasis.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt,
dunkler Urin und
glänzender Stuhl ist sehr wichtig.
Können wir bei
weiteren Erkrankungen dieses Zeichen
sehen?
Choledokalitiasis.
Okay, aber Ihre Verdachtdiagnose
ist Akute Pancreatitis.
Aber Akute
seit vier Wochen hat der Patient
Choledokalitiasis.
Das ist Akute Pancreatitis unter
chronische Pancreatitis, glaube ich.
Okay. Und ich habe
ich glaube,
der Patient hat drei Monate Choledokalitiasis
in letzter Zeit. Ist das schlimmer geworden?
Seit vier Wochen
hat er.
Okay, wir können diese Situation danach
wieder besprechen. Und
welche Differential Diagnose
kommen in Frage?
Akute Choledokalitiasis, die Differential Diagnose
kommen Akute Choledokalitiasis.
Und, ja,
Gastroenteritis,
Apancitis im Betracht.
Apancitis? Oberbauchschmerzen?
Ja, sie hat Bauchschmerzen
und Apancitis kann
mit Bauchschmerzen
anfangen. Aber seit vier Wochen?
Ja, seit vier Wochen ist
ich glaube,
eine Perforation
ist möglich bei diesem Zeitraum.
Okay. Gastroenteritis oder
Choledokalitiasis.
Was noch?
Was könnte es sein?
Ja, Myokartinfarktus natürlich.
Myokartinfarktus kann unter Bauchschmerzen
verstehen.
Ja, oder es gibt auch
leichte Erkrankungen.
Wie Ulcosventrikulie.
Ist es nicht möglich?
Ulcosventrikulie oder Gastritis?
Nicht möglich? Gastritis ist nicht möglich, aber
Ulcosventrikulie.
Ulcosventrikulie? Ja, Ulcosventrikulie ist möglich.
Was planen Sie?
Sie haben eine Verdachtdiagnose
und ein paar Differenzialdiagnose.
Was planen Sie? Um meine Verdachtdiagnose
festzustellen, würde ich als erste
Maßnahme eine körperliche Untersuchung
durchführen. Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
rechne ich inspektatorisch
Ikterus
Kuhleinzeichen,
Grey Turner-Zeichen, aber das
tritt im schlimmsten
Fall auf.
Und ja,
palpatorisch rechne ich
Abwehrspannung,
Druckschmerzen.
Was noch?
Das ist eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Ich glaube, wir können alle Untersuchungen
durchführen.
Was noch? Sie haben eine
Koleidokylithiasis, solche
Differenzialdiagnose. Gibt es ein bestimmtes Zeichen?
McBurney-Zeichen? McBurney,
ich glaube, das ist für Apalaisites.
Nein.
Ja, M, aber ...
Murphezeichen, ja.
Während der Einatmen
der Patient hat Schmerzen, ja.
Während der drücken, der Patient stoppt
die Einatmen.
Oder während der tiefen Einatmen
drücken wir ...
Okay.
Was planen Sie noch?
Dann würde ich eine EKG schreiben lassen.
Eine kardiale Ursache auszuschließen.
Natürlich würde ich die Parameter messen.
Und ich würde ...
Die Labuntersuchung ist unerlässlich, deswegen würde ich Blut abnehmen.
Bei der Labuntersuchung würde ich
Leberwerte, Lirenwerte,
Entzündungsparameter,
Blutbild, Pankreaswerte
wie Aminaz, Lipas, Polestaswerte,
Elektrolyte, Blutzucker.
Pankreaswerte ...
Welche Pankreaswerte
sind sehr wichtig?
Lipas.
Lipas ist sicher.
Aminaz ist auch wichtig.
Aber welches ist wichtiger?
Lipas.
Sie haben auch gesagt
Kolestasewerte.
Was meinen Sie mit Kolestasewerte?
Ich meine Alkalen, Phosphatas
und GGT.
Gamma-Platamin-Transferase.
Kolestasewerte.
Ja.
Bilirbin, ja natürlich.
Und Elektrolyte.
Blutzucker, Hemoglobin A1C
und Urinstatus.
Stuhldiagnostik.
Das ist die Labuntersuchung.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich
Bauch-Sonographie durchführen.
Gegebenenfalls oder unbedingt?
Nach der Labuntersuchung
Wenn bei Labuntersuchung
Aminaz Lipas erhöht ist,
würde ich sofort
einen Bauch-Utraschall durchführen.
Wenn es nicht erhöht ist,
brauchen wir keine Sonographie.
Nein, brauchen wir nicht.
In der Zentralnotaufnahme
nach der körperlichen Untersuchung
und Blutabnahme würde ich sofort
einen Bauch-Utraschall durchführen.
Okay, okay. Entschuldigung, Herr Kollege.
Ich wollte nachfragen. Okay. Welche
Außer-Sonographie?
Ich würde die Sonographie durchführen.
Das ist Goldstandard.
Und ja, am häufigsten
Ursache ist Stein. Deswegen würde ich
RCP planen.
Okay.
RCP ist zum vollen Diagnostik
heißt auch Therapeutikmethode.
Okay. Ist das unbedingt
oder ist das eine dringende Situation?
Nein, das ist nicht dringend.
Sie haben gesagt,
Akute Pancreatitis. Welche
Ursachen sind möglich?
Stein, Alkohol.
Okay. Wenn es Stein gibt,
wenn es Stein gibt oder wenn
die Ursache Stein ist,
sollen wir RCP durchführen.
Ist das dringende Situation
oder können wir zum Beispiel ein paar Wochen,
ein paar Tage warten?
Eine gute Frage.
Oder es gibt
auch alkoholische,
Akute Pancreatitis ist möglich.
Wenn der Patient alkoholische
Akute Pancreatitis hat, sollen wir
RCP durchführen?
Als Diagnostik können wir durchführen.
Aber bei Stein können wir auch
Therapeutik durchführen.
Okay. Wie können wir unterscheiden?
Der Patient trinkt zu viel Alkohol.
Ja, sie trinkt zu viel Alkohol.
Aber ich meine...
Ich habe falsch gesagt.
Alkoholkonsum ist am häufigsten Ursache
bei Akute Pancreatitis.
60% glaube ich. 90% bei
Chronisch Pancreatitis.
Die Gründe sind nicht Ursache.
Am häufigsten Ursache ist
Alkoholkonsum. Dann Steine.
Okay. Es gibt zwei wichtige Ursachen.
Einige Akute Pancreatitis
Ich meine,
wegen Cholestas und
zweite ist Alkoholische.
Wie können wir diese zwei Situationen
unterscheiden?
Gibt es Unterschiede?
Als Laborwerte oder
als Klinische?
Klinische oder Labor?
Ich brauche Ihre Hilfe.
Ja, Laborwerte ist sehr wichtig dafür.
Der Patient hat...
Ah, die GdT ist erhöht.
Ja, Laborwerte erhöht oder nicht.
Und die MdV ist auch erhöht.
Wir können durch diese Werte
unterscheiden, ob der Patient
Alkoholische oder Beliere oder Pancreatitis hat.
Richtig.
Ich glaube, wir haben
diese Diagnose festgestellt.
Wir brauchen eine Therapie.
Wie können wir diesen
Patienten behandeln?
Ich würde die Patienten
stationär aufnehmen.
Dann würde ich einen Zugang legen
und mit Flüssigkeit mit Elektrolyte beginnen.
Dann würde ich Schmerz
und symptomatische Therapie
einleiten mit Analgetika,
Antiemetika.
Dann gebe ich
Antibiotika.
Nährung ist sehr wichtig.
Oder er muss
fettarmer...
Ich habe Nährung-Currents
empfehlen.
Das bedeutet, er isst nichts.
Ich empfehle auch eine Alkohol-Currents.
Okay.
Lebensgewohnheitenveränderung.
Ja.
Was noch?
Und Sie hatten gesagt auch RCP?
Ja, RCP. Wenn er Stein hat,
empfehle ich RCP.
Oder plane ich RCP.
Empfehlen Sie Cholesthektome?
Gute Frage.
Wenn Stein in der
Kalle Blase liegt, natürlich
empfehle ich Cholesthektome.
Aber am Anfang
RCP ist wichtig,
wenn es Cholestase-Seichen gibt.
Ja. Aber wenn es
kein Cholestase-Seichen gibt,
ist es nicht eine dringende Situation.
Ja, wie Sie gesagt haben,
Nährung-Currents und Volumen
zu geben
und Analyse-Currents
sind akute Behandlung, akute Therapie.
Ich habe noch eine andere Frage.
Und meine letzte Frage, Herr Kollegen.
Okay.
Der Patient
hat keine
alkoholische Geschichte.
Der Patient hat auch keine Cholestase.
Was könnte es sein?
Welche Ursache
könnte es auch sein?
Es ist eine Abkürzung,
Idiopathie, Galensternose,
Ethanol, Trauma,
Skorpion.
Das ist ein Tier,
ein giftiges Tier.
Und Mumps,
das ist ohne Speichel.
Und A,
ich habe A vergessen.
Steroide, Medikamente.
Welche Medikamente
können Ursachen verursachen?
Welche Medikamente?
Drei wichtige Medikamente.
Vielleicht nicht so wichtig für die Prüfung.
Ich habe es gelesen. Ich wollte mitteilen.
Tiaside.
Ja.
Und Azatopilin.
Und Valproat.
Antipleptik.
Aber Tiasid ist beliebtes Medikament.
Und
Ok, vielen Dank für Ihre gute, schöne, tolle
Vorstellung, Herr Kollege.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen
und bitte nehmen Sie Ihr Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen
Erfolg in Ihrem
Arbeitsweg.
Danke, Herr Boris.
Ich wünsche Ihnen
Glück.